so hello everybody i am here with jacob
russell jacob lives on the west coast
and and yeah i met him a few years ago
as i was going to speak at a catholic
event and since then he's been more and
more involved in the discussion he's
leading the facebook group that talks
about symbolism that discusses subject
from my brother's book but also from the
videos and widens the topic of symbolism
to a whole bunch of stuff he's also
running a discord server about this
discussion and also I mean Jacob and I
have just been becoming friends slowly
through all this time so I really
enjoyed talking to him so I'm gonna ask
me a few questions about the group and
then also some specific questions that
he has on theology and Tim Maximus the
Confessor
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
originally from the Midwest I've been
out here on the west coast for about 20
years I have four kids
I got twins on the way so I'm really
going through the rad trad phase
[Laughter]
so and for about the four when I moved
out here to Oregon I was kind of your
Pentecostal Chris Mader Christian for a
few years and I started noticing a lot
of things that seemed off to me and so I
was asking a bunch of questions just
trying to figure out why I was more
interested in the aesthetics of of
things so so while I was doing like
worship music with the Protestants
called worship music leading you know
the band style stuff and I started like
thinking about like why does this look
like a concert so I could doesn't seem
like Christians always had concerts you
know and I just started questioning like
the layouts of the church and and
everything and I started asking
questions and nobody had any answers for
me
and so I started looking into more
deeper theology and that just nobody was
having any answers for me so when I
started looking deeper I started looking
into the historicity of Christianity and
he for whatever reason the Atheist point
of view was what grabbed ahold of me and
I just dove down that rabbit hole and
then became a kind of a closet atheist
for a number of years and became a
little bit more militant about it mostly
online and so that lasted for about
eight or ten years I think Wow okay yeah
for a long time and then then I just
discovered Jordan Peterson at some point
and just because I started noticing all
that because I was also becoming quite
progressive during this time - which was
more of an interest in an idea or an
ideology that wasn't familiar to me
because I grew up in the Midwest so very
conservative so I was it was
it was kind of like I was looking back
it's like I was trying on different
clothes and so progressivism liberalism
was just something I was trying on for
awhile and eventually just started to
just just rub me the wrong way and
everything was getting to be in this
weird controlled aspect of it like
trying to trying to pin everybody down
even though it was you know the use of
the word liberal would think more
freedom but here you were like their
ideology was like no you can't go here
no you can't go there you can't go over
here you have to think this way so when
I started questioning all this which was
about the time the Trump came up then
eventually I discovered Jordan Peterson
and he was an interesting interesting
guy to say the least
and I started listening to some of his
lectures and he just totally dismantled
my ideas of religion so I wouldn't say
that he he helped me become a Christian
but he at least helped me
concil religion I guess and see the use
in it and then all came on the screen
and I was like I don't know what this
dude is talking about but I was like I'm
gonna look into it a little bit more and
then you started posting more videos and
then somewhere along the line I figured
out that I started putting two and two
that orthodoxy wasn't Jewish and it was
actually Christianity so I started
looking into it right and and from there
I just kind of like just started diving
deeper and deeper into orthodoxy and it
started with your talks
and death to the world yeah website and
and then yeah so then I started just
watching all your videos and trying to
understand what how that what that meant
for being a Christian in world today and
I needed to talk to somebody and I
couldn't talk to anybody nobody had any
idea what I was talking about when I
would bring it up so I just was like I'm
just gonna start this Facebook group
okay it's like maybe I can get people to
to come on here so and I just invited
all my Facebook friends at first and
actually I think you were probably the
first member I think what is the first
and then like the next day everybody
else came on and I don't think anybody
still had a clue what was going on and
it just slowly morphed into what it is
now so we've been going for he's been a
year and a half and there's over 700
members now so I keep saying that once
we get 777 then I don't know we'd like
reached you know theosis or something
for a Facebook group we're Facebook yeah
so so yeah so so I started that and
discussions have been really helpful and
to just working out what's going on in
my head and seeing what other people
think and it's been just it's been weird
and fruitful and then I
I decided to start a discord server
because I thought there might be more
retraction for other people that don't
like Facebook because a lot of people
are really against Facebook so I started
that and the discord group is is good
there's some really really good people
and decent discussions going on but it's
not as activist yeah as the Facebook
group yeah so I'm not starting any more
group so after this I've got I got a
start on another group for my kids
coming here right yeah so yeah that's
that's pretty much I mean what what has
really what I've been happy to see with
the Facebook group is to notice the
level of discourse that has been going
on there
it feels like I mean obviously just like
any Facebook group sometimes things
things get get heated a little bit but
most of the time it's extremely
informative and cordial and what's great
is I'm there are some people who are
posting things that are really pushing
some aspects of symbolism that I haven't
taught about like there was someone
forget his name was posting best things
about best cieariy symbolism so yeah
taking one animal and then quoting some
putting up quotes about this animal and
yeah so there's been a lot of yeah it
just feels like it's been complimentary
and I've learned quite a few things you
know I go in and I kind of follow I
don't comment a lot but I try to see
what people are saying and get a sense
of what's going on so I'm pretty happy
about that I'm just I was happy to see
people I'm the same with you you know
it's I'm in the same situation you are
in the sense that you know before before
I made during Petersons let's say it was
met here and I and that was it there's
nobody else who could talk about the
stuff with just felt like we were just
these two people discovering this in our
own world you know and then and then all
of a sudden when I met Jordan Peterson I
felt like he had this he had a symbolic
intuition which I'd rarely encountered I
was one of the first times where I could
speak at a certain level and I knew that
he understood what I was talking about
so I was excited and now all of a sudden
yeah all the sudden now there are all
these people that they'll write me
messages and I'm like wow this person
has such a good intuition about you know
these structures it's almost natural for
them so yeah I think it's great to have
a network of people that
understand this and I can understand to
how for people sometimes when I make a
video I realize okay I'm I'm right now
I'm preaching to the crowd because I'm
taking for granted that the people that
are gonna watch this understand the
basics of it so I'm not gonna explain
basics every time I can understand why
someone also would drop into a video
like that and think okay this is just
this is just nonsense or like no one
knows when he's talking yeah no no
whatever you talking about yeah yeah
that's a it that quite a bit cuz I'll
like I'll see other like outside of the
group in other discussions and I'll drop
like one of like a video beers that they
happen to be talking about like the
other day somebody was talking about
dog-headed men so I I put a link to that
article that you wrote in Orthodox Arts
Journal and I was like hey I got the
response that I figured they were just
like yeah whatever is they don't know
we're talking about there it's like
they're more everybody's so focused on
which is fascinating to me it's that
that that people are so focused on the
material that they don't realize how
much they're there they focus on that
only so cuz they were more like trying
to figure out okay how is this like
physically real how or dog-headed people
physically real what kind of like
experiment happened you know 100 years
ago
oh yeah aliens paint it aliens but it's
aliens exactly yeah it's been it's been
it's so and now and now that I've been
like in this discussion for for a couple
years now like I just see like I can't
even imagine how you and Matt to my I've
been functioning for so long because
it's like yeah you kind of feel like
you're a madman sometimes you know
because it's like you want to say things
and you're just like mmm nope nobody's
gonna understand what I'm saying
yeah and look insane so just gonna just
buckle down and log on Facebook yeah but
in a way it was I think it was good
because for the years I would say that
like almost 20 years that we were
working on this on her own and thinking
about it I also was constantly
to formulate ways to at least address
this you know with people and so I feel
like I found some analogies that if I'm
in it I'm in a situation where nobody
understands I can say things I can talk
about you know that's why I use images
like the medieval village or I try to
use really concrete images of something
that you can portray in your mind so
that it's not so it's I not always talk
about the abstract stuff and I always
try it one of the things I try to do is
I if I'm talking to somebody who doesn't
know a lot about symbolism without
talking about symbolism directly what I
try to do is I'll up in the discussion
I'll shift between the individual and
the communal level while I'm speaking so
it's like I'm talking about something
and then all the sudden I'll switch to a
higher level of existence right and then
and then come back so the person is like
whoa what happened because I can see the
analogy you can see that okay here's the
structure I'm talking about something
that have a sudden I'll talk about a
body in terms of a city or in terms of a
larger being and then then I'll come
back down to the person then maybe I'll
go even higher and so and so it's like
I'm not I'm not telling you about
symbolism I'm actually taking you by the
hand and I'm gonna you're gonna take you
to these little spark moments where you
can see the connections you're so
hopefully that'll spark your curiosity
to then go to then go further but you
know it's not easy to talk about this
stuff it's not easy yeah but it's it's
fun though I it sprint because I also
like I try to introduce my kids to a
little bit and they're just like sure
dad well you know there's a good way to
do it this is how I did it with my son
especially is if you notice a pattern in
a story then what I'm what I've done is
I'll tell us some fairy tales like I'll
tell them some fairy tales or some
stories from ancient myths or some Bible
story and then once I feel like they've
heard enough stories of a with a certain
pattern then I'll just say hey did you
notice that this story has the same
thing as that other story did you know
right like do you notice that you know
you you know that the easiest one is the
idea of going down somewhere and coming
back up you know you say y'see do you
know
how they go down and come back up or
that there's this movement and so hell
yeah yeah yeah hey what other story has
that think about it what are the store
has that and then think about it now my
son is he's pretty good at identifying
things sometimes that I didn't even
notice he'll say yeah my it's funny cuz
my son my son does that to he's 10
but he'll he's he was telling me that
him and my eight-year-old daughter will
their watch some show and my daughter
will get upset whenever the hero is like
getting beat or whatever and he's like
don't worry the hero always gets back up
again I'm like it's like yeah he does
that's pretty that's pretty good you
notice that it's like you ever hear that
before he's like you know and so we
started talking I started talking about
all the other sources like oh yeah he's
like it's like that's like everywhere
right it's like it's at that pattern
you're talking about when you're old how
old how old is your oldest he's 10 yeah
okay yes I mean I think this is a good
time 10 but you'll see it I think that
if if you if you work on the patterns
and at some point it's like for me
Alizee was when he was like when he hit
puberty I feels like his mind you know
it's like when you're 12 routine and
your mind starts to really kind of smell
that like really kind of takes shape and
so then all of a sudden became more
explicit for him and he started
mentioning it like okay yeah yeah that's
interesting cuz he my son at least
notices that there's a pattern
hmm he doesn't know what the pattern
means but he notices that you know the
hero always gets beat down but then gets
back up again that pattern he's he's
pretty consistent with or he whenever he
was like two or two or three years ago
he was telling the story that he was
just making up as he went and it was
about these dragons and it was like it
was like all these good dragons all had
like this like elemental aspect to them
and there were against this one dark
dragon and and they had to like what was
it and I think he even had even threw in
some sort of resurrection story and he
was he was like seven
I was like yeah I mean it it just comes
natural to you that's amazing
ya know that that kids can recognize
that but they have no idea what they're
talking about yeah but it's still it's
still quite fascinating yeah and the
idea is that those those patterns are
really what would make us let make us
like they they they they participate in
who we are and so it's actually the
alienation is actually a work that the
world does on us it's a there's actually
work you know you have to go to school
and you have to be you have to be
alienated systematically in order to to
that to break and so the whole modern
world is like you know because it's on
the fringe it's it's it's acting as a
deconstructive agent it's still part of
the meta pattern but still it makes it
more difficult for people to see pattern
because when you're in the fast when
you're in the spinning spinning and the
and the upside down and the crazy then
it's harder to see the pattern alright
yeah and that's one of the reasons why I
talk about that all the time because I'm
trying to say okay is this is actually
part of a bigger pattern which is that
things move towards this this madness so
it's like you can't get away from it but
it's true that in this moment it can be
harder for people to see you see that
the regular patterns you could say so
right right alright so what so tell me
let's talk about what you wanted to kind
of talk about you've been reading st.
Maximus um and and what are that tell me
what are the questions that you were
coming to well so it's it well so one of
the interesting things about this was I
started I started looking at like the
way that the church was laid out you
know and then I and I was kind of doing
some research just kind of like not
really looking for anything just curious
about layout and diagrams and I noticed
there was some sort of correlation
between the Jewish temple and the parish
right and then I stumbled upon a few
other people were talking about how the
Garden of Eden was laid out very similar
yeah in in you know in very abstract
idea but and I was like this is
fascinating so I was looking into this
more and more and and then I started
thinking about how you know what those
things like meant and then you came out
with your that hezekiah ISM video that
you did with the thinker in seattle
whenever he did that whatever yeah and
so that like that really helped put some
things in perspective right and then so
i I was trying to understand like where
who else was talking about this and this
whenever I discovered st. Maximus and
and then I realize also that other
people talk about it st. Gregory and a
few others but anyway that as I started
reading the specific book that he wrote
which was the thing is called the
ecclesiastical mr. Gogi or the church's
mr. Gogi depending don't the concept
that you were talking about how the
heart is like there's like an image of
the church the church is even as a heart
and there's a cosmos all of that makes
sense but then you get to the part of
the soul and I'm just it's like it it
was like nothing nothing about the soul
makes any bit of sense to me
no IIIi don't know why I mean maybe it's
like maybe it's because I'm always
thinking of spirit and not of soul and
yeah I'm not quite sure if there's a
distinction and and like I understand
the concept of the noose you know but I
know that orthodoxy goes deeper and
explain some of these things I haven't
really looked into that too much but
especially whenever he's whenever so
maximus splits the soul into two
faculties right and one of them is a
thing to call it yeah intellectual and
the other ones vital and it kind of
breaks them both down into one
one the intellectual side through
contemplation and knowledge and wisdom
leads you to truth into knowing truth
but then the other aspect of it is seems
like it's more related to the physical
like doing good and then when those two
things come together it reveals God okay
right so that's what he's basically
saying I have no idea how to apply that
does that make sense lie to your life
yeah like how does one like he wrote it
for a reason it's like okay now what you
this is it's fascinating but how does
that how does that like push you more
into the liturgical life or guide you
into prayer at all okay what I mean well
the first thing I mean the first thing
that I that you presented is very good
because the first thing to understand is
is that words like soul are contextual
often and they don't always refer to the
same thing it seems at least in my when
I read when I read it they don't totally
seem to - sometimes the the soul and
body will be opposed in the sense that
everything that's invisible is a soul
and everything that's visible or you
know his body let's say something like
right and then sometimes like you said
then the soul can be separated into two
the intellect which would be the noose
and then the the soul proper or the
vital soul that's a good way to talk
about it which would be the in-between
thing the thoughts the desiring capacity
all the invisible aspects of us that are
kind of like the motor for action you
could say or the motor for four things
it's okay so the the problem in the way
that that it's it's understood that the
body is not is neutral
at the body the body is not the body is
almost like like the the earth and the
creation sense it doesn't have value
it's just there's nothing wrong or good
about body it's just like a muscle sin
is not related to body for right right
it's the passion it's the in-between
part which is problematic then between
in between parties what will then you
fall into let's say when you fall into
the body it's not because of the body
it's because of the it's the desiring
capacity it's the in-between capacity
which is focused in the wrong direction
right okay so instead of looking up and
which would order the body
it looks down and then the body it'll
idolize the body or idolize the the
bodily function or fear for the bodily
functions or whatever and then that's
what ends up it's one of the things that
ends up bringing about sin right so so
so that's important to understand and
Christian in the creek because we're so
we're so Gnostic it's so hard to break
the Gnostic thinking we always tend to
think you know spirit good body bad will
have that it's so engrained into us but
Christianity is really not about that
the problem happens in this desiring
capacity and so so then you can
understand but then you can like you can
still have soul body in the sense that
the soul informs the body but then you
can also have it as noose and soul where
the intellectual part informs the should
at least inform the soul so that's
that's also that's also a thing that's
important in understanding symbolic
structures is that
contextual right go you can understand
let's say the temple or the tabernacle
the whole tabernacle is is feminine in
relation to God
right okay yeah now when you get into
the tabernacle then the Holy of Holies
is masculine in relation to the rest of
the temple or the rest of the tabernacle
and then the whole tabernacle is
masculine in relation to the rest of the
creation
huh but does that make sense so it's
like yeah yeah yeah
so that can that can maybe help you to
understand why it's like why is it why
is it's feared and so like why is he
talking about that is because the this
the let's say the the the soul is the
body of this of the noose and then the
body the physical body is the body of oh
so it's like it moves down that way
right yeah yeah okay yeah that's making
more sense now that helps out so you
have so that's why also when I when I
talk about things like
I talked about hierarchies and
principalities you always have to
understand it something above is the
principle of the thing below but it's
also it can also it's also the body of
something which is above it right right
does that make sense so it's like yeah
think think things are not it's not like
there's just so each level has a
masculine and feminine aspect and it's
necessary for that because they need
people misunderstand so many things
though that's why it's a it's like if
you want to symbolically understand a
queen how do you do that if you can't
understand how at each level of a
hierarchy let's say there's both a
feminine and masculine aspect depending
on which direction it's looking right
does that help you to make a little bit
more sense of why there would be let's
say the news the soul the body and why
he's talking about the relationship of
the news and the soul as similar or akin
to the relationship between say God and
created something like right yeah yeah
that yeah that does yeah and I think I
yeah I don't even know it's such a heavy
thing you know and and so foreign to so
foreign to the way that you that you
just interact I get I guess you you do
interact in the world that in that
manner you just don't realize it right
you're just not even ever thinking about
it yeah so you can then you can
understand that every time you I mean if
you if you're attentive to yourself
you'll notice that all sin is born in
thought and desire right right it's not
born in the body right the body the body
will express yearnings let's say but
it's in all the sinning all happens up
up up at the middle part you know and
and depending on how you direct your
attention and how you where you direct
your will that's where the that's where
the problem arises which is which goes
back to take every thought captive yeah
right you know because yeah once you cat
if you
captured within your thought process you
know it's almost like once it becomes
once it does apply to your body then it
becomes more concrete and more rooted
right you can help you understand then
why let's say for saint gregory of nyssa
or for some of the more mystical fathers
they'll talk of the soul as the beloved
right they'll talk of the soul as the
Bride of Christ when they talk about the
images in st. Gregory Mesa when you talk
about in the song of songs and this
relating to between the lover and the
[Music]
relation to between the lover and the
love ye I guess right Yoga is between
God and the soul because in that
relationship then God acts as the sole
access as feminine right and like I said
you can flit you can keep you can flip
it where it's like now the invisible
part of the person it becomes like
masculine in relation to the body yeah
okay so it's all it's all about it's all
about hierarchy and how each level
interacts with the one above and below
hmm okay so and then so if if using
these principles then what
is there is there a way that like if the
soul I conforms the body is there a way
that the body the actions of the body
what what do they do they do something
for the sölden in return
well they offer this they offer the
support for the soul to manifest in the
world which is why the boys have money
right so which is it this is why it's
important to actually go through like
the more physical aspects of like say
prayer like your prostrations and you
know when bowing we you know whenever
you're in church I'm always I'm just
observing how every we all bow you know
at the same time you know to the priest
and it's like it's important I
understand that it is important for the
physical body to to do that because I
and as you're saying it's like it's it
goes both ways the body kind of anchors
the soul maybe yeah makes it real makes
it makes it real in the sense of makes
it grounded right and also right the
fruit it's like that's why this idea of
the fruits you know the the actions of
the body or the visible actions that you
pose there the fruits there the glory of
the of the the soul and there also if
you will in the end the proof of your
not that you're not deluding yourself
right you need to you need if you're not
having fruits in the world then then
maybe you're living and maybe you're
deluding yourself and that happens in
the in the more immediate and it's like
you to love your neighbors and just to
think about it right loving your
neighbor is right is actually doing
things to help your neighbor you know
caring for people is not just in your
mind it it's not enough to just to just
think about it you know it has to
manifest in in the world to a certain
extent if you if you pray for people but
then every time you talk to someone you
bark at them and you you you're annoyed
with them then it's like well maybe
there's some disconnect here right and
that's why that's why I keep saying that
that's why Christ is so bent on
hypocrisy
he's always talking about hypocrisy
because Apocrypha is when the levels are
this there's a discontinuity between the
levels what you want is for everything
to be aligned so you want what you think
and say
and pray for two then align with what
you do in the world those two things
have those the proof that this is the
way that it's really the way is that
they're all lined up lined up right okay
huh okay yeah this is its everything is
like falling in if you could see what's
in my head everything is kind of like
Tetris falling into place right now so
okay and so you can understand so the
thing is that in terms of if you're
trying to make sense of let's say the
analogies between the the church and the
the person it actually just depends you
always it's like enjoy and it's over you
can understand like I said the invisible
and divisible then you'd have the
relationship of something like the Dome
of the church and the body and the lower
part of the church the Dome of the
square then it's like the invisible and
divisible or the heaven and the earth
right then it's like soul in the basic
sense of all that's invisible about you
and then body in the sense of everything
that's visible about you mm-hmm but then
it like I said it can also be you know
like the mother of God can be an image
of the body in the strictest sense but
then it can also be the mother of God
can also be an image of the soul
in relationship to Christ as well so you
see that in Sager of Mesa he says that
the whole purpose of life is that you
give birth to Christ right that is what
you are that is what we're all called to
do is to imitate the mother of God and
giving birth to Christ in our soul see
that so then it's like then the soul
becomes the body and of this of the
light of that of the spark of the divine
spark so you have this divine spark
hidden in your news let's say and then
you have the soul and so that's where
the relate the relationship happens mmm
but you could also see it said you could
also see it as just a whole invisible
and visible right and then in in the
more so in the church the Holy of Holies
where the priests deacons are coming out
that's that's like the that's the visual
that I'm thinking of right that you're
talking about that's because they're the
Holy of Holies represents the soul and
then the North or the nave is like the
body well it depends you can you can
really like I said it's really it's
really a hierarchy and so everything
okay so let's say a person is spirit
soul and body right that's the way to
see it so you could see it as the church
you have the Holy of Holies which would
be the news which is hidden right and
then you have the the soul would be well
that's it the narthex can be the body in
us in a certain sense but the cruder
aspect of the body would actually be the
would be that would be the no sorry the
nave would be the Mary right body but
the cruder aspect of the body is
definitely the narthex artex right it's
like this chaotic space it's a mixture
that's all this thing all this stuff and
it right it comes to be aligned with so
it's so like I said it's it's better to
see once you start to see the structures
it's not it's not so important to align
things like this is that this is that
this is that because inside so if inside
the hollow yeah okay you have a
microcosm of the same thing so inside
the Holy of Holies you have the Holy of
Holies but then you also
the altar and then in the middle of the
altar then you have a cup and then in
the cup you have the presence of God so
you have another hierarchy inside by
Holy right yeah it's like he's getting
smaller and smaller and smaller right
and deeper and deeper into reality until
it's in this invisible transformation
yeah okay the whole church has to be
that body - and so the whole church has
to become for the world what comes out
of the Eucharist to the church right the
body of Christ
right that's what me aren't supposed to
be - goes to be right yeah which yet
okay get the sense of these fractals
once you get a sense what you're really
able to see the world in fractal you
start to see that it's not so much about
aligning things as - notice the
structure how it repeats itself in
different ways in different okay yeah
okay so one thing you just said though
was you're talking about the noose is
hidden and so that would be like the
like the Econo status is is what's
hiding it right so then what about so
then what do you think about these
churches that have done away with those
yeah you know and I and I think that
it's I think that it's a
misunderstanding of the gospel and I
think that it's also a misunderstanding
of of Christ but it's also a reaction to
an excess it's always that's right I
think it's always you know it's like I I
disagree with the revolution I don't
want
I think killing the king is wrong but I
also I can I can see why the revolution
came about like and so see why it
happened even though I disagree with it
you know right and so it's like I can I
can see why a teenager's rebellious to
his parents can still think that that's
not good and it's not good for that
person's soul but I can still see that
there we go yeah it's all right
no but if you look at the Russian Church
as time went by the wall between the
between the the the the
between the knave and a holy holy place
and the altar just just ended up
covering the entire space filling up
like there was caused off you know and
so what I think is is normal is is a
sense that Christ Christ opened the the
curtain great ripped the curtain right
he went in but then without the curtain
you don't have a ripping of the curtain
you need to read you need to always read
always me rip it yeah you have to you
have to you have to retail in order to
unveil because you if you unveil at some
point if it's just unveiled then you
actually people don't know there's no
mystery anymore right right and so it's
like until what so the way that I think
it should it should be is that there
should be a curtain at least that gets
pulled it gets open it's closed and open
so there's just like there's this
opening and closing of the holy holy
place Fred you understand the problem
that we do have access to to the
spiritual world we do have access to the
noetic but it's also closed off to us
closed off to the time most of the time
we're mostly it is but but it's not true
that we don't have access to it that's a
that's a that's also that's also a lie
right way we in a way we secretly always
have access to it because it's that
which informs the world and didn't once
in a while if we are in a for attentive
if we pray if we do all these things if
we captured the thoughts like you said
then we have more glimpses of noetic
insight you could say right so okay um
so let's go off the sole thing for a
second because the Veil the veil thing I
gotta let that simmer for a while but
the veil is interesting so how does the
iconostasis and like even even the
eucharist cup is it's veiled right so
how does that apply to a woman who is
suppose it's supposedly supposed to be
veiled you know during during liturgy
and during prayer
well there's is that something because I
read something and my wife actually said
this to me and I don't know where she
got she can't figure out where she found
it but it had something to do with
covering that which gives life um well
yeah I don't know I don't know if that
that's a way to see it I think that they
are actually there are two reasons
they're kind of two reasons for the veil
one has to do with with hierarchy if you
read the actual text here in st. Paul
when you talk about that a woman should
be veiled because of the Angels right
they're talking about the hierarchy of
principalities he's saying that there
needs to be these buffers between the
different levels of reality and the
danger of removing them it creates a
kind of it can create a monstrosity like
if you if you well that's a good it's a
good it's a good let's say it's a good
way to understand it it's like if you
remove completely the aganist assets and
you open up the holy place then what
ends up happening is there's a there's a
monstrosity which appears which is that
we don't we don't approach it with the
reverence that we should there's a crow
profanation they profaned the higher
things or we profane that we profane
things they end up end up being people
like the end of people in advertisements
talking about mindfulness and all that
crap you know like people who say I'm
one with the universe right
nonsense it's like it ends up being a
kind of profanation of something which
is supposed to mean everything but now
because it's been thrown out it's like
pearls to swine people can say things
like like I'm saved by Jesus you know
say that and it's like what are you
talking about it doesn't mean anything
you're not talking about reality you're
using words that are supposed to be
extremely precious and extremely
mysterious and now you're saying you're
just like saying I'm saved by the blood
of the
and it's like do you even know what
you're talking about anyways sorry for
the rant but that's one of the reasons
why we need veils is to prevent that
kind of nonsense right hmm and so on the
one hand there's this idea of protecting
the lower from the higher so the woman
is veiled because she is she's the say
she's represents our world she's
represents to say that the earth and so
you have prevent you have to have layers
between so that you don't get this
throwing pearls like profanation where
things fall in it's like nothing means
anything but there's also another reason
why women are veiled which is the
opposite and that's why it's so
fascinating is because the woman is also
the Holy of Holies and so we have to we
also have to veil her from us uh-huh and
that's the that's the strangest aspect
of it it's like you we also have to
protect the mystery in the sense that as
the holy of holy brings the bread to us
right that's also where life like you
said life comes like the feminine and so
we need to you need to protect that
mystery there has to be a kind of a kind
of protection for the so when you're
when you're so a woman in us in a sense
that a woman is for each man a woman is
his holy place to a certain extent in
the reason is in the strictly man wife
relationship and so there has to be
there has to be a mystery there there
has to be a protection so that in the
intimacy of that you have with your wife
is something which is precious and kept
just for
just for just for yeah so it's all it's
all of that that's happening at the same
time that's that's the way that's the
way I understand it it's a it's a it's a
tough stuff it's a tough thing to talk
talk about cuz it's so controversial
right yeah uh Wow you're gonna piss off
a lot of feminists right now okay yeah
that's that one's kind of really I'm
speechless
obviously that's kind of okay little bit
yeah that's the way that that's the
that's also the thing about the feminine
which is which is difficult for people
to understand is
is how it
it's like how a wife is the glory of her
husband right right and so what does
that mean man that's some intense
language and the the feminine the
feminine is kind of like the separation
of the waters where you have the waters
below and the waters above right both
feminine you can understand it that way
you could under sail you can there's a
way in which you can understand the
waters above as being as being masculine
but there's a way also where it's also
it's also this thing that surround like
I'm doing right okay yeah Wow sorry to
freak you out there stuff like that yeah
really
uh yeah okay that's really tongfu okay
so I don't even know where to go from
there yeah no it's good it's good cuz
now yeah this is gonna give me something
really really chew on for a while
well that's why you know if you look at
a lot of if you look at for example at
the Middle Ages at the European Middle
Ages okay if you look at the manner in
which Knights spoke of the lady right
and the idea of of the veneration that
they've had towards the mother of God
but also the veneration that they had
towards their lady in general right in
when you see that that's when you can
understand this holy of holy aspect of
the feminine where they they venerate
the feminine as the sacred place and so
and so the veil that the woman wears is
is a kind of is it kind of
fighting of that mystery of the mystery
of the holy place from the onlooker from
from right right from those that are
outside of the mystery right and so and
that's in that sense you can really see
that you can really understand it
especially in courtly love in the
courtly love symbolism you can really
see that that's what it's about it's all
about this this idea and masculine even
more so it's so it's like the the night
had a very very strong veneration of the
mother of God more than anybody else the
Templars for example you know like if
you read some of the writings they were
extremely dedicated to our lady because
it's also like I said it's also about
this you know as the masculine figure
venerating this holy place
said in st. Paul it's also presented the
other way where it's also it's also this
this lower the lower aspect of reality
which needs buffers in between it in
order to not in order in order to not
let's say create it a descent the thing
that you see in Genesis where it says
that didn't up long yeah the idea of the
the sons of God going into the daughters
of men but you get this like thing above
which goes straight to the thing below
without going through the normal level
then you get a monster and and you can
understand it in so many ways you can
understand it in the in the 20th century
we had exactly that problem where let's
say in the in the Middle Ages again you
would have a king but nobody ever saw
the king right people didn't see the
king the king was in his castle and and
anyways all these people were there and
the king would would say something maybe
once a year you would see them and then
most of the time you interacted with
your noble and your noble then would
have access to the King once in a while
so it was like a normal hierarchy where
things came down to higher but and that
was how government works that's how the
army works that's how all of this stuff
works but then in the 20th century we
created this situation but technology
with all this stuff where it's like you
could have Hitler and you could have a
hundred thousand people standing in
front of them and he would directly
speak directly to the people so you had
the top of the of the pyramid speaking
to the bottom of the line right that is
what in that which create this frenetic
monstrosity that we saw and it wasn't
just Hitler with all the demagogues of
the 20th century you know and that's the
problem of the demagogue in general is
like someone who wants to be the head
but then has direct access to the the
lower the like the masses without going
through the proper channels and almost
all the revolutions happen that way but
it exactly that like instead of going
through the normal instead of going
through the normal methods of the Senate
and all their laws that he went straight
to the people and started right you know
speaking directly to the people that's
how you cause a revolution you know and
so and you can actually see this in the
language that many Protestants speak
where they're like they don't need the
Saints they don't need the Theotokos
they have direct access to Jesus right
is there something like that when Zurich
access easing direct access to God if
they do exist right right it's me and
God you know it's like God and God is
telling me what to do and and so yeah
and I mean obviously yeah yeah I know I
don't want to get to doing down there
it's fascinating okay so that makes it
the Protestant world really fascinates
me anyway I was only in it for such a
such a short time you know but it's
looking now that I've been away from it
for so long looking at it how much it's
it's everywhere and it's just it's just
like well I mean just the way it's set
up you know the the people are looking
at whoever is talking to him you know
it's all just facing each other it's
like that's no different than anything
else no it's no different than a
business meeting or a concert so yeah so
anyway that was a bit of a tangent
okay hopefully but I'm hoping that that
might help to understand that the
question of the veil or the question and
yeah that is so important I mean it's
alright
understand even if we don't you know
even if we don't most people don't wear
veils today but like to understand the
importance of veils in the sense of this
importance of a hierarchy having levels
and having different transitions between
all the different levels because if you
don't then then that's when you get yeah
yeah problem that's that's and that's
the I mean that's I was thinking of the
house like that's what the house is -
the house is just a series of veils
between every room yeah you know and as
you go deeper and deeper into the house
you know I think you're what yeah you're
even talking about that I was like
there's a certain part where everybody's
welcome on the on the porch a few people
are let in to the living room not too
many people are let too far past exactly
of that right yeah and we can understand
what kind of monstrosity would happen
right let's say if you brought your sex
life out on the porch I don't know right
and that I mean then it would be that's
what a prostitute does right take that
that's what that's what you know that's
the dissipation you know and so so you
wouldn't unless if you want a family you
definitely won't want that you don't
want to just go out and have sex with
all the strangers you want that you
wanted to be produced into your bedroom
was just you and your wife okay that way
you you keep the mystery and you prevent
this kind of monstrosity of dissipation
which would lead which would be the
other other but mm-hmm okay
yeah sex is always a good analogy in
reality yeah everybody understands sex
yeah release I think they do alright
yeah okay how does this relate back to
the soul well if you read revenue so you
will see that that if you read the the
his reading of Song of Solomon yeah
that's how he sees the relationship
between God and the soul he sees it as a
sexual edit and all the sexually and in
Song of Songs is used to to exemplify
the way that God interacts with the soul
right that's and that's interesting
because it's like the the more erotic
language it's kind of taken out of
Christianity he says nobody wants to
talk about it which is so interesting to
me because it's like sex is everywhere
but they don't want to talk about it in
how it relates to Christianity in a way
I guess well you know what I mean I mean
we are I mean are let's say for sure the
the Christianity took up such an
aesthetic practice that that it a lot of
the type of language that would be used
in that case would probably have been
reserved to to monastics you know it's
probably not everybody would be reading
st. granitas commentary on the song the
Song of Solomon
um but it's still there it's still there
in its not as it's not a obviously not
like the song song because that is
extremely explicit if you read that in
it so it's always sexually evocative but
it's so it's still there in the idea of
the bride we still have the language of
the bride we still have the language
this the language of uniting heaven and
earth all of that is still it's still
there but it's not it's definitely more
it's more implicit right yeah
okay okay
Wow I think we did a pretty we went
around a few mysteries there yeah yeah
what else we need to solve next week all
right well I'm gonna what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna put I'm gonna put a link to
the Facebook group below and people can
come in and and join it if they want but
obviously there are there are some
moderators and and there won't like I
don't think I mean I don't know how
strict you are but obviously no things
that go over the board get it if you
just spin if you just honestly whenever
you first get into the group and you
just look at some of the posts you can
see how people are reacting to each
other and I've kind of updated and put
some rules there you know just like you
know come on don't be an idiot I mean
it's actually it's okay to be an idiot
just don't be a jerk yeah really and
even that's even kind of like it's
because there's there's two monitors and
there's me and another guy Bradley yeah
and it's like we were talking I think we
were talking about this like she's
definitely the right hand and I'm
definitely the left hand so Bradley will
Bradley will drop the hammer you know
and I'll kind of be like oh well you
know let's just let's see what else this
guy has to stand it's good we need a
good cop bad cop thing yeah yeah so but
it's good and like yeah and it's if if
you if no one has been in there it's it
really is and most a lot of people have
said this it's a nice place to go and
explore ideas without you know the best
word I can think of an autistic behavior
yeah yeah and one of the things I
noticed too is that even though I would
say probably there's probably the
majority or Christian or identify as at
least sympathetic but it's not everybody
there's I saw the Jews there are people
from I think I think they're maybe even
Muslims and just agnostics and stuff
yeah it's it's I think there's a pretty
good like the majority of people in
there if you put them into groups the
largest group is probably Orthodox but
barely and then and then Catholics and
Protestants but it's hard to it's hard
to figure out
the Protestant because everybody kind of
is their own different version of
Protestant so but yeah but there's as
far as I can tell we've done a few polls
and yeah it's we have everything
everybody's in there some yeah in some
aspect every every everything is in
there everything is there's a little
cosmos there it's a little cosmos yeah
it is all right well it was great to
talk to you again Jo you do yeah and
we'll stay in touch okay yeah all right
if you enjoy the symbolic world content
there's a lot of things you can do to
help us out you're not subscribed please
do go ahead and share this to all your
friends if you can get involved in the
discussion we have a Facebook group in
which people can talk about these
subjects I will put all those links in
the description and also if you can
please support us financially by going
to my website